ابو محمد
اكثر من 24 ساعه قبضتها جنان تحت ركام
الزلزال في مدينه حارم شمال غربي سوريا
نجت بعد ان اصيبت بجروح بليغه وانتابتها
حاله نفسيه سيئه بعد شهر من الزلزال تعاني
جنان من متلازمه هرس الاطراف وفي ذاكرتها
القريبه صور قاسيه ليوم الكارثه يوم فقدت
فيه والديها واربعه من اخوتها تحت الانقاض
ولن يتبقى لها سوى اخيها عبد الفتاح لا
يتوقف عن البكاء ومناداه امه
[موسيقى]
يعني عم بحاول جهدي انه طالع من هالحاله
اللي هي فيها بس يعني حاله نفسيه منهاره
كتير وبدها اشخاص معينين يعني ومخصصين
نحن بنحاول جهدنا نطلع من هالحاله اللي هي
فيها
اخضع يوميا لجلسات علاج وهو ما شكل ضغطا
اضافيا على صحتها النفسيه حسب ذويها امام
جنان واقرانها من المصابين جراء الزلزال
وقت للاستشفاء من جراحهم قبل ان ينتقلوا
لمرحله العلاج والدعم النفسي وهذا ضروري
حسب الاطباء وضروري ايضا للاطفال الناجين
من الكارثه حتى من دون اصابات جسديه في
احد مراكز الايواء للناجين من الزلزال في
ادلب دقائق فرح
[تصفيق]
متطوعون متخصصون بالدعم النفسي يساعدون
النادين من الاطفال في منطقه الزلزال
تخفيف من توتر وقلق الاطفال قد تستمر هذه
الانشطه من خلال انشطه منظمه الى سنه حتى
نتاكد من ان الاطفال تعافوا من اثار
الزلزال وعادوا الى حياتهم الطبيعيه
الاف الاطفال شمال غربي سوريا يعانون من
صدمه ما بعد الزلزال حسب فريق منسقه
استجابه سوريا
ويحتاجون الى علاج ودعم نفسي منتظم خصوصا
بعد انقطاعهم عن التعليم جراء دمار
المدارس والمؤسسات التعليميه في مناطقهم
ادهم ابو الحسام الجزيره